[Music]
now martin concerning our next episode
of what's a prof
episode 59 we
have a situation that even though we
don't take
sides in the issue as always
but do present some of the views in the
world out there
regarding the events that are occurring
in the world today
this episode would perhaps be safer on
alternative platforms
yes could you perhaps enlighten the
viewers
as to what the procedure will be okay
because of the community guidelines we
thought it might be
better to start off just on the
alternative platforms that we've got
we've got this
links to the alternative platforms in
the description of this video that we're
making again
and also remember that we cannot
premiere the video on those platforms
so if you go to those platforms it might
show there as a private video but six
o'clock on thursday
south african standard time it will go
live
as always as always so always at the
same time it will be live
but it will be on the alternative
platforms
correct the future ones will again be on
the normal platform that we always use
it'll be on youtube
but this particular one just to
ensure that we do not pick up
any problems we will place it only on
the alternative
platforms yes and as you say it will be
very clearly marked
and the links will be there people can
click and it will say
what will it say it will show
alternative platforms and a link to
every single
alternative platform where you can go
and watch it okay and even though it
doesn't
premiere it says private
it will go it will go live at 6 00
p.m south african time as with all the
others
yes thank you okay
you